on sera tous comme chaque semaine france
info et l'ina vous offre un voyage dans
le temps à travers les archives de la
télévision pour décrypter l'actualité
notre dossier du jour est consacré à la
peine de mort parleront aussi de roland
garros à la télévision avec un invité
exceptionnel vous regardez l'inattendu
et vous étiez bienvenus
là monsieur bonsoir je voudrais regarder
la france au fond des yeux
sinon j'aimerais beaucoup qu'ils en
apprennent à tricoter d'accord là-dessus
à votre place je la ramène un peu moins
mais si vous ne réussissez pas c'est
qu'il vous manque qu'une seule chose que
tout petit détail le trophée les valises
à paris de ce qui lui arrive est valable
à mes côtés ludivine lopez et géraldine
corner lavaud journaliste à la rédaction
de l'ina bonsoir mesdames vous avez
décortiquer les grands titres de la
presse cette semaine et deux sujets ont
plus particulièrement retenu votre
attention
ludivine vous c'est la fermeture des
salles de sport oui une fermeture en
raison de la circulation active du
coronavirus elle concerne les gymnases
et les salles de sport dans plusieurs
grandes villes françaises
un coup dur bien sûr pour les
professionnels de santé mais pas
seulement pour les sportifs aussi car
les français ont pris l'habitude de
justement pratiquer ce sport en salle et
spa nathanaël géraldine aussi les
français d'ailleurs ont découvert ce
sport en salle à partir des années 60
regarder tout un monde de machines
atteint ici la femme d'aujourd'hui qui
veut garder ou retrouver la silhouette
idéale cette fameuse silhouette qui
donne un souci la machine à galbées les
jambes
la machine à affermir la poitrine la
machine à affiner les mollets et les
cuisses
350 centres de ce type fonctionnent dans
le monde où l'on pratique méthodiquement
la chasse à la cellulite paris est
désormais un des bastions de cette lutte
au finish le soleil finira bien par
apparaître
et avec lui les robes légères alors les
parisiennes ne manqueront pas d'armes ne
pour gagner la bataille de la beauté je
pense qu'on est en 1965 alors vous
géraldine vous avez un petit chouchou et
cette semaine c'est hugo gaston et
pourquoi donc mais bien celle là
surprise de roland garros cette année et
il a fait vibrer tous les fans de tennis
dimanche alors qu'on ne l'attendait pas
c'est hugo gaston et je ne peux pas
m'empêcher de vous montrer et bien sa
première télé c'est france 3 toulouse il
avait 12 ans et il était déjà présenté
comme un futur champion on regarde
vraiment on se met au plus près d'une
situation de match réel pour hugo et
l'ol
ce sont les dernières consignes avant le
tournoi des petits as 12 ans à peine en
5e tous les deux et déjà des heures de
tennis à leur actif une rnd miloud angie
après le mardi une heure de physique
deux heures de tennis derrière mercredi
une robe de physique deux heures de
tennis jeudi deux heures de tennis ou
vendredi ils n'auraient physique deux
heures de tennis et le samedi
ça dépend des fois j'ai joué une heure
et demie dans mon club
sinon repos la hugo gaston au tournoi
des petits as c'était il ya à peine sept
ans il a un peu changé quand même le
jeune homme alors ça c'était pour
l'actualité des derniers jours mais
sinon que s'est il passé le 7 octobre
ces dernières années c'est le zapping de
l'ina ça s'est passé 1 7 octobre
regardez bonjour l'antisémitisme comme
toute forme de racisme et d'une atteinte
monstrueuse à la dignité humaine toni
morrison est la première femme noire à
recevoir la plus haute distinction
littéraire
j'écris pour créer de la vie à partir de
ce qui m'entoure qui n'est que chaos
misère morts c'est à 18h45 qu'est tombée
la confirmation de la maison blanche les
etats-unis viennent donc de lancer une
attaque sur l'afghanistan ce côté face
la statue du génie celle du sommet de la
colonne de la bastille à paris côté pile
sa valeur 10 francs et le millésime 88
avec l'automne voici robinet le salon de
l'automobile qui est fait aujourd'hui
son 50e anniversaire
la de jeux pensait prendre une traction
avant est dans cet esprit l'un des clous
de cette manifestation les héros du jour
ce sont eux et pour la circonstance ils
ont sorti leur plus beau collier pour
l'heure m pas question de rater cette
rare occasion ça changera pas sa vie
mais bon c'est comme ça
elle s'appelle mireille et pour la
première fois elle se promène d'un mont
pellier un genou découvert
qu'est ce que vous en pensez quoi il
faut pas m
tellement de la poêle bonsoir et à
demain
[Musique]
et notre dossier du jour est consacré à
la peine de mort un sujet qui fait débat
et qui divise toujours autant ludivine
vous avez ressorti un micro-trottoir de
1972 avait reposé la même question cette
semaine
oui on adore ça allait dans la rue posé
la même question que dans l'une de nos
archives
cette semaine avec tarifs qu'elle dit on
a demandé aux passants s'ils étaient
pour ou contre la peine de mort voici la
réponse
je lui qui a tué quelqu'un qui a man je
suis contre la peine de mort la justice
ne peut pas être rendu de cette manière
[Musique]
vous êtes pour ou contre la peine de
mort madame gisti
vous l'écris tous les gens qui donnent
la mort là méritent aussi est ce que
vous êtes pour ou contre la peine de
mort monsieur je suis totalement contre
contre contre résolument contre
personnellement mes convictions sont que
tout le monde a le droit à la vie qui
s'est contentée n'arrange rien
c'est pas nous à juger les autres celui
qui a tué quelqu'un qui a man doit être
plus on le branche fonctionne pas suffi
qu'il explose et place de la concorde y
aurait moins de vanity fair qu'on
aimerait le récupérer
c'est pas comme ça qu'on traite les gens
fin tout simplement on est dans un pays
civilisé
honte à revenir à l'âge des cavernes
même tu me dis qu'il ya trop de chance
en fait qu'il soit pas coupable et
confiant
et si quelqu'un de votre famille par
exemple du catering et demain dans les
coffee shops
je suis également contre yverdon mais
c'est quand même con
on les condamne en effet travaillé toute
ma vie pour la société voici quelques
heures de votre famille par exemple
était assassiné demain dans des
conditions épouvantables vous seriez
également contre ça c'est la question
qui tue je peux pas me prononcer là
dessus parce que ça m'est pas arrivé
mais je pense que je serais contre cela
en souffrance mais malgré tout je fais
confiance à la justice c'est pas à moi
de juger ça et j'espère qu'elles sont là
j'aurais circulent alors vous l'avez vu
les personnes interrogées aujourd'hui
sont majoritairement défavorables à la
peine de mort contrairement aux années
70 un constat à nuancer tout de même car
hors caméra certains avaient parfois un
discours moins modérée et je le rappelle
cet exercice n'a pas valeur des sondages
justement vous parlez de sondage un
sondage récent révèle que les français
sont aujourd'hui favorables au
rétablissement de la peine capitale
tout à fait le mois dernier un sondage
ipsos pour le journal le monde révélait
que 55% des personnes interrogées
seraient favorables au rétablissement de
la peine de mort ludivine quand est ce
que cette division des français face à
la peine de mort apparaît pour la
première fois à la télévision
et bien c'est au tour des années 70 à
peu près nathanaël à cette période
plusieurs affaires judiciaires vont
largement être médiatisé je pense
notamment à la sphère patrick henry cet
homme reconnu coupable du meurtre d'un
enfant de 7 ans en 1976 une histoire
macabre marqué par ce moment de
télévision
regardez oui la france a peur et nous
avons peur et c'est un sentiment qu'il
faut déjà que nous combattions je crois
parce qu'on voit bien qu'il débouche sur
des envies folles de justice expéditive
de vengeance immédiate et directe
et comme c'est difficile de ne pas céder
à cette tentation quand on imagine la
mort atroce de cet enfant
la france a peur cette phrase culte
prononcée par le journaliste roger
gicquel va renter bon nombre de français
au point même de faire oublier l'autre
propos vous l'avez entendu à nathanaël
du journaliste il appelait aussi à ne
pas céder aux envies de vengeance ou de
justice expéditive
c'est important parce que cette phrase
prononcée par roger gicquel est souvent
sorti de son contexte on comprend mieux
en tout cas ce qui est exact le
journaliste a voulu dire à cette
époque-là faire patrick henry électrise
le débat sur la peine de mort oui
d'autant que le meurtrier va échapper à
la guillotine un verdict inattendu à
l'époque obtenu par son avocat robert
badinter et surtout en contradiction
avec l'opinion de la majorité des
français
la preuve dans ce reportage en novembre
quelques mois après la condamnation de
patrick henry à la perpétuité
on a eu dans mon sort de ce soir que
trois quarts des français étaient pour
la peine de mort est-ce que vous
rejoignez oui alors tout ce qui est
écrit gratuit le propos des intentions
je suis pour la peine de me voir et je
crois que dans tout mon entourage
c'est l'avis unanime je n'ai pas trouvé
jusqu'à présent de gens qui ont prétendu
inverse à l'ats l'avocat abolitionniste
robert badinter qui va jouer un rôle
très important dans ce dossier sa voix
pèse dans ce débat sur la peine de mort
à plusieurs reprises
il souligne la division des français il
va le faire pendant ces plaidoiries
robert badinter a défendu plusieurs
condamnés à mort mais aussi sur les
plateaux de télévision en 1979 par
exemple malgré des sondages encore très
favorable à la peine capitale
il notait le début d'une prise de
conscience écoutez le depuis la rentrée
judiciaire c'est-à-dire depuis le 15
septembre
huit fois on a demandé la mort et huit
fois les jurés l'ont refusé c'est ça le
fait ce n'est pas le propre des avocats
ou des avocats généraux ce qui est
important c'est l'attitude des jurés
n'essayez pas une contradiction entre
cette attitude des jurés et les sondages
d'opinion qui révèle une majorité en
faveur de la peine de mort lorsque on
pose la question abstraitement êtes vous
pour ou contre
on répond abstraitement et généralement
sans avoir eu le temps de bien y
réfléchir mais les jurés sont interpellé
directement par la question de la peine
de mort c'est dieu qui se prononce or ce
que nous avons depuis des années c'est
un véritable référendum négatif je le
dis sans arrêt l'immense majorité des
jurés se prononce contre la peine de
mort et puis arrive la campagne
présidentielle de 1981 les candidats
n'ont pas le choix ils doivent prendre
position c'est un tournant et les deux
finalistes
affrontent sur la question le président
sortant valéry giscard d'estaing à
droite françois mitterrand à gauche
l'abolition de la peine de mort je le
rappelle faisait partie du programme du
candidat socialiste
le 10 mai 1981 mitterrand est élu malgré
des sondages encore majoritairement
défavorables à l'abolition preuve une
fois de plus de la contradiction des
français sur le sujet et pour mener à
bien sa réforme françois mitterrand
choisit bien sûr robert badinter
oui robert badinter est nommée garde des
sceaux et le 17 septembre 1981 soit
quatre mois seulement après l'élection
de françois mitterrand il présentait son
projet à l'assemblée une date marquée
par ce célèbre discours je dis
simplement rappelant la phrase de jaurès
puisqu'à l'évidence en vous sa parole
n'est pas éteinte la peine de mort est
contraire à ce que l'humanité depuis
2000 ans à penser de plus haut et rêver
de plus noble ce débat il a été diffusé
à la télé c'est ça exactement et en
direct c'était une première dans
l'histoire de la télévision
preuve de la vivacité et de l'enjeu du
débat le texte est adopté à l'assemblée
puis au sénat le 9 octobre 1981
l'abolition de la peine de mort est
officiellement est officiel pardon en
france malgré une opinion publique
encore une fois majoritairement
défavorables je rappelle cette année là
63% des français se disaient contre
cette abolition
voilà le débat sur la peine de mort
expliquée par ludivine lopez merci
beaucoup
ludivine
[Musique]
c'est chaque année un des évènements du
sport français et de france télévisions
roland garros a débuté malgré l'épidémie
moins de public mais toujours autant de
téléspectateurs l'histoire du tournoi
est intimement liée à celle de la
télévision et nous allons vous raconter
pourquoi avec notre invité
c'est jean paul loth ancien joueur
ancien dtn
ancien capitaine de l'équipe de france
et surtout l'un des premiers consultant
sportif du tennis à la télévision vous
commentez d'ailleurs toujours en ce
moment le tournoi
jean-paul aujourd'hui roland garros est
un des événements sportifs les plus
diffusés 6500 heures de matchs diffusés
dans plus de 210 pays trois milliards de
téléspectateurs cumulés c'est énorme
n'en a pas toujours été ainsi géraldine
et non pas du tout on va rester à
l'échelle de la france et il a fallu
vraiment du temps pour que le tennis
s'impose à la télévision que le tennis
français s'impose à la télévision parce
que tout simplement le petit écran se
trouvait face à un dilemme plutôt simple
à comprendre comment adapter les
contraintes de grille de programmes avec
des matchs dont la durée est par
définition aléatoire contrairement à un
match de rugby ou ou de foot par exemple
alors à ses débuts et bien la télévision
ne diffusait que des extraits de matchs
dans les informations du soir on peut le
voir là sur les archives il faut
attendre 1960 date à retenir pour voir
pour la première fois la finale hommes
des internautes des internationaux de
france de roland garros
diffusé en direct à la télévision en
voici un extrait l'huile de 19,2 à
roland garros pour assister à une volée
de ayala qui est dans le deuxième jeu du
premier set qui l'opposait contre jerry
dans cette finale des internationaux des
64e internationaux de france mène par 1
jeu à 0
ayala est au service il a donc gagné le
service des étrangers ti pour le premier
jeu alors le voir cette finale de roland
garros hommes de 1960 est un peu pauvre
au niveau de la réalisation mais c'était
une prouesse technique est une prouesse
technique qui avait quand même ses
limites car sir le macis le match et
bien diffusé en direct les
téléspectateurs et bien ils ne verront
pas la fin de cette finale ça peut
paraître surprenant surtout pour pour
une finale où on est on attend vraiment
les dernières minutes mais voilà comme
ans
ce passé écoutez nous sommes pape est
disposé à rester mais je pense qu'il ya
un tas de programmes qui sont pas vus
depuis fort longtemps
à la direction des impôts directs sur
des programmes qui te manque le sois
obligé très certainement de rendre
l'antenne de toute façon avant la fin du
match on indique simplement que je peux
garder l'antenne
hilarant d'ailleurs c'est à dire le vent
au moment où il ya la rive étrangers
vivant de revenir sur le court pour
continuer à se disputer le gain de cette
finale des 64e internationaux de force
ces parisiens de la qui sont là nous
allons le quitter à regret car je pense
que nous ne le retrouverons pas je vous
redis simplement pour la bonne
information que qui étrangers dit
pendant cet instant de repos est parti
avec 1 7 d'avancé
les paris sont ouverts pour la suite des
événements je crois que vous connaîtrez
de résultats définitifs tout à l'heure
par la bouche des journalistes sportifs
au journal télévisé ici roland garros de
diffusion télévision française les paris
sont ouverts donc non qu'on pouvait pas
il fallait attendre le journal du soir
pour savoir si c'était l'italien nicola
pietrangeli où le chilien luis ayala qui
allait gagner cette finale donc c'était
nicola pietrangeli qui a gagné en cinq
sets
inimaginable aujourd'hui d'attendre
plusieurs heures avant d'avoir la fin
est d'avoir le résultat de la finale de
roland garros
on se ferait vilipendé ça ne pourrait
pas s'en réfère évidemment mais on vit
quand même des moments où de temps en
temps quand il ya d'appuyer pas lui dire
je vous ai je vous ai vu sourire jean
paul parce que finalement ces matches
interrompus avant la fin et les
téléspectateurs mécontents et ils ont
raison va finalement ça reste quand même
un classique à la télévision on se
retrouve avec des matches on est obligé
alors aujourd'hui grâce à france
télévisions on change de chaîne tout
simplement changer puis on peut le faire
avec les moyens qui sont maintenant
employé pour éliminer ce type de
problème les toits dans tous les
tournois du grand chelem
ils sont apparus ce n'est pas pour le
tennis que c'est venu ne faut pas que
les gens s'ils tombent c'est parce que
la télévision depuis les années la fin
des années 60 et 70 est le principal
moteur de l'évolution du tennis dans le
monde parce que auparavant ça ne se
diffuser pas les gens ne voyaient pas le
tennis mais il y en a qui sont pas
trompés à ce sujet c'est lamar hunt
et certains grands financiers américains
qui sont il faut changer d'horizon fait
un truc terrifiant ils ont créé des
intervilles la wct il ya eu plein de
compétition qui ont vu le jour parce que
en amérique qu'on s'est dit le tennis ça
va être porteur et ça va rapporter de
l'argent et du coup en 74 en france on
en n'était absolument pas là vous allez
le voir parce que les matches sont
toujours diffusée filmée en direct pour
la majeure partie mais les griffes de
télévision ne sont toujours pas adaptées
à ces matches qui peuvent avoir des
durées complètement aléatoire donc on a
vu en 1960 comment ça se passe et
regarder 14 ans plus tard on est en 74
eh bien c'est la même
voilà nous allons être obligés de rendre
l'antenne pour suivre des 24 heures du
mince et d'un moment peut être un peu
mal choisi mais qu'est ce que vous
voulez à vous le main voilà on sent le
valais veut dire la déception près comme
au désespoir de commentateurs du marteau
de matthieu lartot de l'époque danser
dans ces propos c'est difficile on
pourrait même pas l'accepter ça serait
déjà sur le plateau avec les techniciens
une autre alors pour toi à cette époque
là la compétition et et mieux couverte
un par la télévision française
et figurez-vous la télé qui montre la
télé un grand classique
ça fait déjà l'objet d'un reportage oui
on est en 1974 et c'est le journaliste
christian qui dès qu'ils parcourent les
allées du stade de roland garros avec
philippe chatrier en personne président
de la fédération française de tennis et
il visite les coulisses de télé pas peu
fier 1 on regarde je continue moi de
vous faire visiter également la
télévision philippe yacé grand chose ces
gros camions c'est ce qui nous permet à
tout cet ensemble de camions et de
matériel eh bien c'est ce qui nous
permet d'assurer des images en direct
nous le ferons pendant toute la semaine
en direct de roland garros et tous les
jours
j'ai aussi bien sur la première que sur
la deuxième chaîne ceci est un camion
qu'on appelle le camion d'accompagnement
où il y a tout le matériel les
kilomètres de câbles les caméras qui
pèse très lourd enfin c'est un énorme
travail pour nos amis technicien
et ça n'est pas toujours facile vous
savez on connaît plus volontiers le
commentateur voir le réalisateur et on
oublie trop souvent qu'il y a énormément
de garçons très compétent qui font
marcher tous ces engins très compliqué
est ce que je peux vous dire justement
saisir cette occasion pour vous dire
combien nous sommes sensibles au fait
que toute cette télévision directe va
être donné au public français
et combien en fait vous nous obliger à
nous battre pour garder ce tournoi car
ali pas possible on n'a pas le droit
quand vous faites des efforts que vous
faites pour envoyer dans les plus petits
villages des images de tennis de ne pas
tout faire pour garder ce tournoi en
danger c'est normal que l'on se bat
ensemble car c'est un tournoi de qualité
ça fait partie des événements sportifs
que l'on aimerait voir garder sur le sol
français voyaient qu'à la vitre là notre
ami envie carrier qui est le réalisateur
de cette émission il fume toujours sa
pipe de temps en temps il se faire et se
fait amener un petit verre de vin rouge
tout de même car c'est très c'est tout
de même très dur de rester
vous savez que henry carrière est aux
manettes de 14 heures à 19 heures cela
suppose cinq heures d'attention soutenue
dans ce cas archives
exceptionnel excusez moi je vois ça m'a
déconcentré
en revanche quand on préparé ce rendez
vous jean paul vous m'avez donné deux
noms sur l'importance du tennis à la
télévision française christian quidet et
philippe chatrier et on les retrouve
dans cette archive qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont fait quelque chose
d'exceptionnel à un moment ça a vraiment
été le boom du tennis en france est par
ailleurs aussi ils ont décidé contre le
patron de la une qui à ce moment-là
voulait vraiment avoir le tournoi pour
lui proposer des sommes d'argent
importantes mais philippe a résisté lits
dont il va falloir que nous trouvions
quelque chose et christian que je vois
wimbledon le 10g la bombe atomique pour
décider philippe chatrier à venir sur la
deux je vais lui faire diffuser le
tennis sur la deux et la trois tous les
jours pendant tout le tournoi juste
juste avant vous allez plus vite que les
archives
juste avant en a justement cet appel de
philippe chatrier on est en 77
il lance un appel donc là à ce moment là
le tournoi était diffusée
essentiellement sur sur tf1 ils lancent
un appel en direct et pour que tous les
matchs choix diffusé en intégralité et
il y va pas par quatre chemins on écoute
notre problème nous c'est de faire voir
du tennis que roland garros où un
instrument de plaisir de propagande
sportive pour toute la france
et bien pour ça il n'y a que la
télévision qu'ils puissent le faire
alors c'est à vous messieurs de la
télévision c'est à vous de jouer
ça n'est pas quand on rajoutera dix
villes place à roland garros qu'on aura
résolu le problème
ce qu'il faut c'est que la télévision
fasse comme dans les deux ou trois
autres très grands tournois mondiaux
qu'elle ouvre ses antennes tous les
jours pour faire voir les meubles de
tennis voilà son voeu est exaucé en 1978
année où vous commencez à commenter les
matches à la télévision jean paul quel
bénéfice ce roland garros cette
médiatisation de roland garros à porto
au tennis français
bon bah ça a été le véritable départ
parce que à ce moment là était arrivé
qu'un hors bord des joueurs peu
exceptionnel qu'on commençait à voir
dans les stades mais il n'était pas vu
encore à l'écran ça commencé aux états
unis à wimbledon
et subitement en france vous
voilà que nous pouvons admirer ces gens
et je veux raconter des anecdotes
quant à l'époque j'allais dans les ca
m'a beaucoup servi à la télé pour ce qui
me concerne parce que j'étais dtn
j'allais dans le plus petit village de
france pour voir s'il y avait des courts
de tennis ont marre et et vous y avez
des gens qui jouent et sur les corrige
on m'a arrêté au troquet du coin
christian parler du verre de vin rouge
moi j'allais prendre le petit blanc avec
les gens du coin jean paul jean paul
mais c'est le tennis a pour aider vous
imaginez ce qui était arrivé à ce moment
là d'ailleurs on a un moyen nous à
linate de quantifier ça on a une équipe
d'experts qui analysent le contenu de la
télévision française et grâce à leurs
statistiques on peut voir l'évolution du
volume d'heures de retransmission de
roland garros et donc la notoriété 1 du
tennis qui qui va avec
regardez en 1978 nous avions 45 eur et
un petit graphique qui va arriver 45
heures de match diffusé en 1978 c'est
140 9 heures quand antenne 2 et france 3
rachète les droits petite baisse du
nombre d'heures de match à la télévision
jusqu'en 2002 où un nouvel acteur fait
son apparition
eurosport et puis nouvelles hausses en
2005 avec l'apparition de france 4 donc
toujours plus de matches à la télévision
l'année dernière en 2019 ce n'était pas
moins pour la télévision française
uniquement 198 de diffusion pour pendant
roland garros de diffusion de matchs ça
a bousculé la télé et ça a bousculé le
tennis aussi bien pour le tennis on
pouvait pas rêver mieux pour que ce
sport soit diffusé constamment et pour
le plus grand public car il ne faut pas
l'oublier
il ya plein de sports qui aimeraient
avoir le quart du tiers de ce que nous
avons pour être diffusée mais il faut le
retenir grâce à cette télévision
beaucoup de jeunes beaucoup de gens
s'intéressent au tennessee parce que
c'est un sport théâtral c'est un sport
qui plaît à l'image et nous on attend
toujours un successeur à yannick noah
jean paul loth merci pour votre
éclairage sur le tennis et sur la
télévision de secteurs que vous
connaissez parfaitement voilà
l'inattendu touche à sa fin comme chaque
semaine on se quitte avec une pépite
la télévision française un hommage à
juliette gréco ses obsèques ont eu lieu
lundi à l'église saint germain des prés
dans cet archipel de 1983 la chanteuse
fait le bilan de sa vie écoutez
mais alors cette vie elle vous apporter
tout ce que vous en attendiez donc vous
attends rien je n'attendais rien et
c'est peut-être parce que je n'attendais
rien que tant de choses me sont arrivées
je n'ai pas fait grand chose pour
attirer sa mémoire
dans mon
hoti je n'ai aucun regret
je n'ai aucun remords je suis quelqu'un
de très reconnaissant quoique la vie et
pu me faire du douloureux j'ai eu des
instants de bonheur tellement fort
que l'on peut dire que merci
[Musique]
voilà on se retrouve mercredi prochain à
21h sur le canal 27 et toute la semaine
bien sûr sur les réseaux sociaux que ce
soit ceux de france info et de lina à
grand merci à celles qui ont préparé
avec nous cette émission magali berlin
eléonore prévaut quand lieu qui
travaillent toutes les deux amina bonne
semaine
[Musique]